主催者：あらためまして 私
日本テーラワーダ仏教協会の会長を務めております
柳  順一と申します
今日は ありがとうございます
私どもの会は  みんなボランティアで
やっておりまして
今日 皆さんの受付をしたり  施本をお渡ししたり
会場案内したり
あるいは 会場費のお布施とかも全部
ボランティアで楽しくやっております
お釈迦様に教えていただいたこと
スマナサーラ長老に教えていただいたこと
というのは もう なかなか お返しすることは
できないので せめて皆さんにお伝えするということで
喜びを感じながら やっております
是非この会が終わってから
そういったボランティアに興味がおありの方は
前の方に  終わってから来ていただけたら
ご説明できると思いますし
ご案内もできると思いますので
是非 お願いいたします
今日は 会場のお布施の方のご芳名
たくさん 載ってますですね
今日は「自己中のススメ」ということで
非常に大胆なタイトルで
カッコ付きの「自己中」なので
当然 我々が普段 言ってる自己中とは
全く違う意味ということですよね
で  ボランティアというのも
カッコ付きの「自己中」に 何か繋がる
ことがあるんじゃないかなと思って
その答え合わせをしようかなと思って
私は今日聞こうかなと思っております
少しでも心に残ることがあれば
もう それで 本当に すごく生活が  人生が
変わるきっかけになりますので  是非楽しんで
聞いていただけたらと思います
もう少々お待ちください
長老：では三帰依と五戒文から始まります
司会：合掌してください
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり  正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に  敬礼いたします
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり  正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に  敬礼いたします
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり  正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に  敬礼いたします
長老：Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ブッダ（佛陀）に帰依いたします
一同：Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ダンマ（真理）に帰依いたします
一同：Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
サンガ（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
一同：Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Dutiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ふたたび、ブッダ（佛陀）に帰依いたします
一同：Dutiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Dutiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ふたたび、ダンマ（真理）に帰依いたします
一同：Dutiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Dutiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ふたたび、サンガ（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
一同：Dutiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
みたび、ブッダ（佛陀）に帰依いたします
一同：Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
みたび、ダンマ（真理）に帰依いたします
一同：Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：Tatiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
みたび、サンガ（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
一同：Tatiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
長老：五戒文
Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「生き物を殺さない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
一同：Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「生き物を殺さない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
長老：Adinnādānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「与えられていないものを取らない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
一同：Adinnādānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「与えられていないものを取らない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
長老：Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「淫らな行為をしない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
一同：Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「淫らな行為をしない」
という戒めを 私は受けて守ります
長老：Musāvādā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「いつわりをかたらない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
一同：Musāvādā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「いつわりをかたらない」
という戒めを 受けて守ります
長老：Surāmeraya majjapamādaṭṭhānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「放逸の原因となり（人を）酔わせる酒・麻薬類を使用しない」
という戒めを  受けて守ります
一同：Surāmeraya majjapamādaṭṭhānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「放逸の原因となり（人を）酔わせる酒・麻薬類を使用しない」
という戒めを  受けて守ります
長老：はい これから「慈悲の瞑想」 いたします
ご一緒に唱えましょう
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
「私は幸せでありますように」と
繰り返し念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願いごとが叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも
悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
「親しい生命が幸せでありますように」と
繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも
悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
「生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように」と繰り返し念じます
はい  ありがとうございます
では  よろしくお願いします
今回の法話会  始まります
「仏陀が教える『自己中のススメ』」という
ちょっと現代的な 逆説的な言葉 使ってますけど
ここで 私は ポイントとして
示したいことが
「自と他の区別を越えること」ですね
それは 仏教的なスタンスなんです
それには 順番に道があります
はい  次の…
で  法話会の会場費のお布施の方々の
名前を出してます
読み上げると時間かかりますが
書上太郎さん　秋本慶太さん　岩嶋圭子さん
清野秀和さん　山縣典子さん　大村恭子さん
田村詠子さん　山田眞佑さん　稲葉比佐子様
瀧澤智瞬様　横谷茂様　和泉直子様　細山美雪様
柳順一さん　藤本竜子さん
それから  前田真理子さん　竹澤彰さん
苅谷光晴さん　武田英敏さん
竹中春美さん　髙橋優子さん
新藤貴久さん
山吹保利様ですね
それからまた もう二人が入っていられます
このお布施をした方々は
お布施の中で法施という一番 徳の高いお布施
功徳の高いお布施になりますので
この皆様方に幸福が訪れますように
安穏になりますように
心が清らかになりますように
解脱に達することが この功徳によって
できますようにと誓願いたします
Sādhu!     Sādhu!    Sādhu!
善きかな！  善きかな！  善きかな！
はい  これで講演に入ります
まず これはページと違って
ちょっと説明したいところがありますけど
「内なる世界」っていうね
英語では  " The world within "
世界っていうのは自分が作るもの
っていうことで
私たちは
世界のこと 知ってると思ってるんです
エラい態度で思ってるんです  世界のこと
まぁ大体 仏教で世界っていう場合は
生命と物質世界 両方入ります
で「知ってますよ」と
「知らないわけじゃない」
という態度で いるんですね
しかし 仏教の立場は
「あなた方は  我々は  世界のことを生命のこと
ありのままに客観的に知ってるわけではない」
っていうことなんですね
[自分のこころの状況  能力によって
認識は変わります]
なぜかと言うと
我々は「物事を知っている」と認識したとしても
この認識そのものが不安定なんですね
時々弱くなったり  時々強くなったり
時々認識自体がすごく荒波になっ たり
要するに 分かったり 分からなかったり
いやになったりで  ハチャメチャ状態なんですね
だから  ずーっと一貫して認識し続ける
わけじゃないんですね
だから あなたが「知ってる」と 言ってるのは
「どんな時の状態ですか？」と聞きたくなるんです
例えば すっごい上機嫌な時は 何でもよく見える
まぁ あの ポジティブに見えちゃうとかね
落ち込んでる気分だったら
周りは全部 何か悲観的に
いやに感じたりもしますね
だから「世界は知ってますかね」
という問題が出てくるんです
はっきり言えば「私はこのように感じます」
ということだけですね  答は
私は  面白いんだから
宇宙物理学的な話は  結構
見たり調べたりはします
それで 「結局 知ったと言っても
知ってるのかい？」と
ある人が言うのは  我々の太陽が
砂一粒だと思ったら
地球にある全ての砂よりも
あの宇宙に  何て言いますか
galaxies（銀河）があるんだよと
だから どうですかね？  知ってますかね？
私たちにとっては  地球にある
全ての砂っていうのは
一個一個 どれぐらいかも分からないしね
galaxy（銀河）と言ったって どんなものか
我々が知ってる galxy（銀河）があって
隣にアンドロメダがあって とかね
でも 知らないね
だから 「自分がそう思う」という
だから 私は科学 何も知らない人だから
まぁ 人の話を聞いて「ああ  そうですか」と
でも  あの喋ってる人は専門家だから
また違う知識 持ってるでしょうねぇ
だから 「私は世界 知ってる」と言うよりも
あれですね  「私は そのように思っている」
「感じている」なんですね
ですから 私たちの知識とは  自分の
[主観的な認識で  主観的な判断であって
真理・事実ではありません]
そこで 問題は 「自分の判断は正しい」
「間違いない」と 人は思うことなんですね
これは どうしようもない病気なんですよ
どんな人も「自分の認識は正しい」
と思っているんです
例えば 花を見てね
この物体を見てね
「これは 本当は鳥の鶴ですけど
私は花だと思います」
ということに ならないんです
これ見たら「花です」と みんな認識するんです
だから 花に違いありません
もし 私が「いえ  これ 花じゃなくて
カラスでしょう」と言っちゃうと
「えっ？」と 私のこと馬鹿にするんですね
「あんた どうか なってるのか」と
そこで自分 知ってる世界が正しい
正しいんだから 他の人 知ってる世界
私に言うと  私はそれに混乱したり
興奮したり 戦ったり 喧嘩したり
色んなことになるんです
だから 相手の意見 直すよりは
自分の意見、見解  正しいかどうかと
そこら辺は 理解して欲しいポイントですけど
私がスライド以外で説明したいところは
ここに入ってないんだけど
次のスライドに行ってみましょうか
はい  ここで説明します
私は どのように世界 知ってるのかと言うと
私に感覚 感じる能力  六つありますね
眼・耳・鼻・舌・身・意（げんにびぜつしんい）と
この感じる能力 六つに 感じられるものも
決まっているんです
センサー  普通に言えばね  あるんだけど
何でもキャッチできるわけじゃないんですね
皆様の家にも色んなセンサーがあるでしょ？
人の動きによって照明がオンになる
センサーとかはね
でも それには 喋ったからと言って
照明は オンにならない
そこで物体の動きが必要でしょうしね
で  それぞれ 我々 使ってる温度計もね
体温測るあれも繊細なんですね
それには 温度は測れますけど
他のことはできません
我々の体も同じで センサー六つ入ってますけど
感じられるものも
すごいリミットされているんですね
仏教では「色・声・香・味・触・法
（しきしょうこうみそくほう）」というふうに
六つであると言ってますね
まぁ そこら辺はご存じの方々は知ってますけど
初めて 話 聞く人々にとっては
ちょっと ややこしいかもしれませんけど
分からなかったら忘れてください
私には 至って簡単です
「色（しき）」っていうのは
目に触れるデータ
「声（しょう）」っていうのは
耳に触れるデータ
目に触れるデータは 何なのかと
ご自分で考えて下さい
どうでも いいんです
しかし 仏教で言うのは
「目に触れるデータは 色と形だよ」と
それで 我々 学校で学んだのは
「目が光を感じるんだよ」と
でも 光を感じても
脳みそが 光を処理しません
脳みそで 色と形を作るんです
いつでも そういうことなんです
空を見ると
我々には
もう何百年も古い昔 発生した光が
当たるんだけどね
例えば 10光年の前の光が目に当たる
まぁ 望遠鏡でも いいんだけど
それで 我々に何が見えるかと言うと
形  見えるんです
はい
それで 「声(しょう)」というのは声
まぁ 声と言っても
実際は空気の振動を感じるんだけど
空気の振動…
空気は いつでも振動していますよ
で 物事は結構 振動してます
で 存在そのものも一つの振動…
一つでは なくて  いくつかの振動ですけど
聞こえません
地球の音は聞こえませんしね
木の音も聞こえませんし
その中で一部の振動は聞こえますね
で  鼻で感じるものに「香（こう）」と言うし
舌で感じるものに「味（み）」と言うし
体で感じるものをね  これ感触ですね
それに「触（そく）」と言うし
それで  頭の中で色んな ごちゃごちゃ
ごちゃごちゃ回転させてますね
その時も 刺激対象があるんです
それに「法（ほう）」と言うんです
まぁ そういうことで 我々は
ある一部のデータを感じて 認識していますね
そこで
「これが私が住んでる世界」
「私が生きてる世界」「私の世界」
「私の世界」っていうのは私の眼耳鼻（げんにび）…
目・耳・鼻などに感じる世界なんです
ほかに あるかないかもわからないんです
例えば「このホールの 外の世界 あるか」と
言うと  皆様は「ありますよ」と言うでしょ？
それは こちらに来る前に見たからな んです
皆様を意識不明状態にして
突然ホールに運んで 意識を覚醒してもらう
そうすると びっくりしますね
「え⁉  どこにいるのかい？」とか
なぜかと言うと この場所を知らないし
どんな地方かも知らないし
外 どうなってるのかも知らない
データ 入ってない
電車に乗って来たんだから
そういうのは 見て経験してるんだから
まぁ 外の世界はあるとは言えますけどね
だから 私が「実際 ある世界」
「本物の世界」と言うのは
私の眼・耳・鼻・舌・身
に感じた世界なんです
友達が「あの  あんた知ってますかねぇ
王子の方で 公園にお化けが住んでますよ」と
「写真も撮れますよ」と言う時
「あぁ そうですか  なるほど  王子の公園に
お化けが住んでる」と自分が思っても
その場合は 友達の声  友達の言葉を
データとして認識したんです
そこで  面白いことは
我々は目に触れるもの  そのまま認識しない
形を作って  それに好き嫌いの価値観も入れて
それから 今までの経験も入れて  認識するんです
皆様に この舞台の横にある この花は
花として見えないんです
皆様の過去の経験  皆様の知識
あれやこれやと混ざって
花ということを認識するんです
そういうことで  私は
「私だけに限った世界」作っているんです
私に この花どのように見えるのか と
他人に伝えることすら できないんです
いくら伝えても 伝えても
その人は自分の過去の経験やら思考能力使って
イメージ作るんです
例えば 今日はできませんけど
皆様にね  「目を閉じてください」と頼んで
私は何かの場面を言葉で説明する
小説のように
東からね そよ風が流れてる とかね
そこで小さな家があるんだ と
家の後ろに りんごの木が立ってるんだ と
そこで なんだらかんだら鳥が
りんごを ちょこちょこっと食べようと
してるんだ と言っちゃうと
皆様の心の中でイメージが現れるでしょう？
それ  私が思ったイメージですかねぇ？
皆様  同じイメージになるんですかねぇ？
もっとシンプルに この舞台の上に
「カンガルー  一匹いるんだと
イメージしてください」と
できるでしょ？
でも どんなカンガルーですかねぇ？
知らない
一人ひとりが 自分のカンガルーを作るんです
実際  カンガルー  動物園ででも見た人が
それに合わせて イメージ作ることもあるし
一番 簡単なのは 本に見た
カンガルーの絵なんですね
だから 自分が読んだ本のカンガルーの絵を
頭の中で作るんですね
まぁ オーストラリアの野生でいるカンガルー
見た人々が 別なイメージ作るかも
とにかく
そうやって  「舞台の上にカンガルーが
いると思って下さい」と言うと
一人ひとりが 自分特有の 他人と全く関係ない
カンガルーを作るんです
だから 私にとっては「あのねぇ あなた イメージした
カンガルーはおかしい」と言えませんね
それは どんなカンガルーか知らないんだからね
「あなた 思ったカンガルーは
ちょっと小さすぎよ」と言えません
これ不可能です
もう一人に指を差して「あなた思った
カンガルーが口に花を咥えてるんだけどね」
「カンガルーはそういうことやりませんからね」
とかね言える？  言えないんです
これ 拡大して下さい
我々は いつだって自分の世界 作ってるんです
それは他人が作る世界とは関係ないんです
他人に伝えることも不可能です
しかし私にとって 私が見たものは本物です
私が聞いたものは本物です
私が味わったものは本物に違いありません と
例えば ハチミツ 食べたことがない人に
普通の砂糖で作るシロップを なめさせて
「これがハチミツだよ」と
「これをハチミツと言うんだよ」と言うと
その人の世界で「あぁ この味とこの感覚が
ハチミツ」という考えでいるんです
そこで やがて後で何日か経ったところで
本物のハチミツを食べさせる
そうすると「え？ ちょっと味が違うね  これは
何か入ってるでしょう」と言うんです
だってシロップは何も入ってないんだからね
ただの砂糖だから
その人は驚いて
「えっ これハチミツじゃないよ」と
もしかすると 皆様のは ビンに入っている
ハチミツでしょ？ 食べているのは
ハチの巣と言うんですか？ comb?
そのまま あげたら「うぇぇ！ これイヤだぁ」
と思う可能性ありますよ
あれ ワックスで できてる  honey…
英語で  honeycomb(ハチの巣)って言うんですけど
その中に入ってるんだからね
あれは そのままちぎって食べられますよ
まぁ ワックスは噛んでも噛んでも
意味がないんだから
飲み込んだとしても毒にもなりませんし
ハチミツを食べて
ワックスの方を出すこともできますし
しかし やっぱり あのプラスチック瓶に
入ってた方がいいですね
それに慣れて そのイメージ作ってるんです
でもプラスチックのビンに入ってるハチミツは
温めて殺菌させてるんだから
あれはハチミツというよりは砂糖水なんです
体によくないんです
どうしましょうかね
どうすることもできない
それでポイントに戻りますけど
「舞台の上にカンガルー がいると思って下さい」
「想像して下さい」と言うと
皆様  一人ひとり 自分特有の 自分だけに限った
他人と共有不可能なカンガルーを作るんです
頭の中で
「こんなくだらない子供の話やめてちょうだい」
という気持ちになってるでしょ？
まぁ そのレベルで考えてください
それでも
と言うことは 私が生きてる世界 全て
私固有の 特有の 他人と共感できない
自分だけの世界なんです
これ 理解してないんだから  人々は
それで誰かが私に「あのね あの何々さんがね
ちょっと何か性格 悪そうね」とかね
「ちょっと態度でかいね」とか言うと
私は「ああ そうですか  なるほど」
「私もそう思った」と言わなくちゃいけない
大変ですよ
私が「あの人 いい人」「この人 悪い人」と
思ったのは  自分で作った世界の問題であって
その人 悪いか いいか  客観的に 科学的に
立証されたわけじゃないんです
ある人が 豆腐を食べて「豆腐というのは
世の中にある美味しい食べ物のひとつです」 と
言ったとしても「勝手にしろよ」と
言うしかないんです
美味しく感じない豆腐もありますけどね
「豆腐は もう いや！」と思う人々もいますよ
まぁ 豆腐の例よりは 納豆の例ですね  [ 笑い ]
これは日本人の間でも好きな人  嫌いな人
居るんだからね
だから 外国人に聞く必要はないね
まぁ 私は納豆食べますけど
で…  [ 笑い ]
時々 外国の方に初めて納豆 見せて
「えーっ！ これ カビついてるもの」
「これ捨ててよ」と  「危険だ」と
言う可能性ありますね
それは その人の認識世界なんです
何かにカビが入っちゃうと それはもう
決して食べてはいけないものなんです
例えば パンとかご飯とか野菜などなどに
カビが入っちゃうと もう食べてはいけないんです
なのに 日本人はカビが入っている大豆
食べているし
ヨーロッパ人はカビが入っている何食べています？
チーズ食べているし
あんな ブルーチーズっていうのは
エラい まずいんだけどね  私にとっては
「えっ？」と思うんですよ  食べてみたらね
向こうは 美味しそうに食べているんです
そういう私が カビが入っている納豆は
「はあ～美味しいね」と思いながら食べてるんです
だから そういうことで 私が
「納豆が美味しい」と言ったからと言って
「納豆とは人類にとって美味しい食べ物です」
とは言えないんですね
それは私の勝手な主観です
それで 私たちは生きてる間で 社会で
トラブルからトラブルでしょ？
うまくいってないんです
親とも喧嘩する
自分の子供とも喧嘩する
友達の間でも色んな対立が起こる
夫婦も喧嘩する
ストレスも感じる
自分が軽視されてる  馬鹿にされてる
と思うこともある
会社で 自分のこと評価されてないと
泣く人々は結構いるんですね
それで落ち込んで  暗い人生 行うんですね
それで会社に行かなくちゃいかんのだからね
行って仕事しても  毎日毎日「評価されてないね
私のことは」っていう気分でいるんですね
だから そういう風に 我々はかなりトラブルだけで
悩み 苦しみに満ちた生き方しているんです
その理由は 認識の問題です
自分が 自分で作っている世界に居るんです
私には 例えば納豆を食べて「納豆って
こんな味ですよ」と人に教えることは不可能です
「これは美味しいんだから食べて下さい」と言っても
そこは大きな誤解が起きているんです
「あのね  これ すごい美味しい食べ物ですから
あなた食べてください」と言ったところで
私は すごい優しい人間でしょ？
だって自分が もらった美味しい食べ物
人にも分けているんだから
違います
私は あんまりにも性格が悪くて
エゴイストなんです
自分の感覚を 無理やり相手に
ぶつけようとしているんです
だから 人の尊厳を侵害しているんです
これは仏教の世界では一番古い経典などで
今日も ひとつ皆様に読んでもらう…
読みたいと思うならば  Madhupiṇḍika-sutta
（マドゥピンディカ・スッタ「蜜丸経」）という
中部経典の18番目で日本語訳もありますけど
日本語訳 読んで理解できるかどうかわからんけどね
結構 難しい経典なんですけどね
で  この認識のトラブルを説明しているんです
これは現代語で言えば
「私は 私が作った世界に生きていますよ」と
「私は世界を創造します」ですよ
エラいねぇ 態度　神様と同じでしょ？
カッコいいんじゃない？
自分が 自分で作った世界で生きているんです
隣の人は その人が作った世界に生きているんです
そこまでは いいんだけど  自由で
「自分の世界観  自分の価値観
相手に押し付ける時 どうなるんですか？」と
これは成り立たないんですよ
世の中 なんでこんなに道徳が必要ですかね？
面倒臭いでしょうに
キリスト教になってくると十戒 ありますしね
各宗教では もうあるわ あるわ
日本でも神社に行ったら各神社によって
色んな しきたりがあるんですね
「これこれやるべきです」
「これこれやってはいけない」とかね
ただ神社に入る時は 何か あの水で
手を洗ったり なんとかやりますね
何の意味か分かりませんけどね
私も やったり やらなかったり 色々
時々 自然の水が流れてる時もありますね
色んな地方で
そのときは やりますけどね
水も飲んだりもしますけどね
ここら辺だったら水道の水だから
まあ「いや」っていう感じでします
あんた手を洗ってないんだから神様は怒る
まぁ どうせ怒ってもいいや ということになるんです
とにかく 世の中…
これはちょっと冗談で 面白いんだからね
誰にも害がない例を出しましたけど
色んな しきたり 習慣 道徳 あれやこれやと
いっぱいある
あっても守ってくれないね
特に学校なんかでは道徳の授業は
一番 人気のない授業
それ言うと 子供達が何か自分のプライバシーを
侵害されたような気がするんです
「嘘 ついてはいけませんよ」て言っちゃうと
「え？ 何様ですか  あなたは」って
気分になるんです
本当は 人は嘘をつかないんです
人は「こういうふうに言った方が
私がOKだ」と思っているんです
それは 別なデータに合わせると
嘘になっちゃいますけどね
とにかくこの問題はもうちょっと高いレベルで
皆さんは 私より勉強している頭のいい方々でしょ？
だから結構 理解できると思います
言ってるポイントは
自分が自分の世界 創造しています
自分 知っているのは その世界だけです
科学者は 宇宙外生命を調べているでしょ？
みんな何を調べるのかと言うと
carbon base（炭素基） で できている
水と酸素を必要とする生命を探しているんです
だから 誰が決めたんですかねぇ？
「生命は carbon base（炭素基）で
できあがらなくちゃいけない」と
「どうしても酸素と水が必要」
誰が決めたんですかね？
だから 例えば流れる溶岩の上で
うろうろと生命が居たとしても
科学的な知識では
あれは生命ではありません
だって溶岩でしょ？
こんな熱いところに！
もしかするとね 太陽の中にも…
太陽は もうほとんど空気ですからね
その中で色んな 遊びながら上に行ったり
下に行ったりする生命が居るかも
でも科学的に  現代我々知ってる科学知識的には
一切 有り得ないってことになるんです
だから 科学者にしても
「私は知ってる  それが真理の世界」
っていうことになっているんです
それで  この個人の世界作ることに
仏教では専門用語で
もう これ すごく大事な言葉で "papañceti"
（パパンチェーティ  妄想する）って言うんですね
papañceti（パパンチェーティ  妄想する）と言ったら動詞
papañca（パパンチャ  妄想）って言うのは名詞ですね
目に何か触れると  光子が触れると
さっさっとパパンチャ（妄想）をするんです
そして自分だけに限ったイメージ作るんです
「 それが事実」と そう思うんですね
そういうことで どんな生命も
特に地球上の生命
人間だけじゃなくて 誰にだって
生きづらいんです
カラスとか ハトとか 東京は色んなところで
巣を作って気持ちよく住んでいるでしょ？
でも 区役所の人々は駆除をするんですね
生きづらいんでしょう？
で カラスは考える
「何するのか  この人は」と
「私は せっかくこの電信柱の上で
巣を作って気持ちよくいるのに」
それはカラスが考える世界
人間が…その専門の仕事やってる人間が
「あ  これ 迷惑だ  危険だ  駆除しなくちゃ」
っていうふうふうに  それは人間の世界で
思っちゃうんですね
そこで どちらが正しいんですかね？
家に居るゴキブリたちが「あ～ いい場所ですね
食べるものもあるし 隠れるところもあるし
暖かいし  じゃあ ここら辺に住みましょう」と
住むことにする
そちらに来る人間が「なんで私が住んでるところに
こんな虫が居るんですか」と
で 「さーっと みんな殺虫剤で殺そう」と
そこで 人間から見れば とんでもないことで
ゴキブリから見たら 人間もとんでもない
ことになるんですね
そういう世界で我々は生きているんです
結局は
「私が知ってる世界が正しい」ってことに
なっているんです
区役所の人々はね  時々
あと一週間で花が咲くのに
桜の枝を全部切って持って行くんです
「何するのか」と そちらの人々が考えても
その業者さんたちが「私たちには
色々 仕事 たくさんありますから
今日は この street（通り）の 枝を切って
おかないと大変なことになるんだよ」と
「もうちょっと 一週間待ってください」と言うと
「いいえ 一週間 待てない
明日は あちら こちら  次はこれこれ」
と言っちゃうんです
だから それぞれ人は「自分が正しい」
という立場で生きているんです
もう分かるでしょ？
「これって おかしい」と
私たちは自分の世界 作っているんです
それで結論に 至って簡単に なります
やっぱり この苦しい世界  このトラブルの世界
対立の世界  落ち着きのない世界
安穏がない世界
この問題解決するためには  自分自身の
認識システムを改良しなくちゃいかんでしょう
要するに自分を直さなくちゃいけない
っていうことに なるんです
そこで 我々の認識っていうのは面白いんですよ
私は ある例えを考えたんだけど
これは 大乗仏教でもよく使ったりするんだけど
自分の心っていうのは  いつでも変化する
変形… 形が変わる何か粘土みたいな
何か液体みたいな鏡だとしましょうか
だから 心っていうのは 液体でできてる鏡
だから 鏡に対象が映るんだけど
鏡の形によって対象が変わりますね？
それは知ってますね？
鏡が へこんでいると でっかく見えちゃうし
上に convex（凸型）になっていると
小さく見えたりするしね
顔が ぐにゃぐにゃだったら
対象も ぐにゃぐにゃになっちゃうでしょ？
これ 粘土…  すごい ぐにゃぐにゃの
スライム・ボールみたいに いつでも形が変わる
鏡みたいなものだったら  心が
映るものは その時 その時の形によって
変化するんですね
だから 事実は映らないんです
鏡が曲がっていると
対象は曲がって映っちゃうんですね
鏡がへこんでいると
対象がちっちゃく見えるんですね
鏡に割れ目が入っていると
見えるものは全部 割れているんですね
すごく割れている鏡で 木を映してみると
木が割れているんです
へこんでいる鏡で木を映してみると
「ちっちゃい木ですね！
何か ちっちゃくなっちゃって！」とかね
だから 自分の心がそんなふうに
いつだって変化する  瞬間に変化する鏡だったら
私は世界を知ってますかねぇ？
そこでポイントは 自分が知っている世界は
正しいと思うこと
「じゃあ 別なふうに思って下さい」って
言ったとしても これは無理です
例えば「舞台の上に居るカンガルーを
イメージして下さい」と
そしたら私は「あのねぇ  あんたがイメージした
カンガルーは ちょっと良くない」
「もう ちょっと大きいカンガルーを
イメージして下さい」と言っても
その人にそれ無理なんです
はい そういうことで「我は世界を知っている」
という立場で みんな生きてるんだから
誰の生き方も 変！
うまくいかない
誰だって生きてる上で作るのは
トラブルだけ　対立だけ
たま～に 仲良くしたりもします
それで みんな 家族仲良くするために
夫婦仲良くするために すごい苦労しますね
会社でみんなと仲良くするために
相当 苦労しますね
会社だったら忘年会  新年会とかあるでしょ？
あれで健康まで破壊する行為に行くでしょ？
何のため？
みんなと仲良くするためなんです
忘年会でもう上の人から普通の社員から
みんな一緒に酒飲んでギャーギャー ワイワイ騒いで
それでみんな一緒になったという錯覚
会社に行ったら終わり 全部
苦労しますよ みんな
だから夫婦も お互い仲良くするために
苦労しています
親が子供と仲良くするために  意見 通じ合うために
結構 苦労します
至って簡単なことは「あなたは あなたの
世界に居る」「私は 私の世界に居る」って
思っていることですよ
"You are living in your world"
"I am living in my world"
”And these two worlds will not crash"
世界 二つ ぶつからないようにするしかないんです
隕石でも地球にぶつかったら
もう… ごめんねぇ！
全部さよならでしょ？
で そこがこの… 論理的な 心理学的な
客観的な説明は そこまでで終了します
そこで私が言いたいのは
「あなた 分かる？　直すべきなのは自分だ」と
「成長するべきなのは自分だよ」と
「大人しくなるべきなのは自分だよ」と
「人を指さすなよ」と
はい  次のスライドに行きます
「他を救う恐怖」
もう そのテーマに入りましたね
[人には○○が必要だと自分が思うんです
それは自分の主観であり 捏造の結果でもあります」
捏造というのはパパンチャ（papañca）
ということでね
そこで 時々自分が「あ あの人に
これが必要です」と思って
「あ これこれ どうぞどうぞ」とあげちゃうんだけど
その人は「何するの  いらない そんなことは」
と 言うかも
言っちゃうと 「せっかく親切にやって
あげようと思ったのに」
と言って ちょっと気分が悪くなりますね
電車で立って（いる人に）
「どうぞ座って下さい」と 言っちゃうと
大体「いいえ 結構です」って
言っちゃうでしょ？  日本では
そうすると 席を（譲って）あげた人は
せっかく（譲って）あげたのに
「何か悪いことを したみたい」と
落ち込んじゃうんですね
だから そういうことが起こるんですよ
座ってる人が立ってる人を見て「この人は
座った方がいい」と自分が思うんです
時々 若いお母さんたちが 子供を抱っこしていて
電車で立っている
誰か座っている人が「どうぞどうぞ」と
「座って下さい」と言っちゃうと
若いお母さんが「結構です」って言う
「何だ  これは？」と思うでしょう
しょうがないんです
若いお母さんは もしかすると
「私は若くて元気ですからねぇ
自分の運動にもなりますしね
痩せるためにいいんだから
子供を抱っこしたままで 立っていますよ」と
あるいは「座るなんて そんな弱い人間じゃないや」
という風に思っているかも
誰も知らないでしょうに
そういうことで 座席を譲ってあげても
断られることはある
あるいは すごく疲れている人が来て
「あのね 疲れたんだから あんた ちょっと どけ
私は座りますから」と言っちゃうと
「えぇ⁉ あんた何者か」と
「なんて乱暴  失礼な人だ！」と思っちゃうでしょ？
だから これは  自分が思う世界を
他人に…
投影すると そうなるんです
相手を理解できればね
例えば ある人は そんなに見た目は
別に何も見えないのだけど 来て
「私はすごく疲れていますから
ちょっと座りたいんだけど
あなたの座っているところいかがでしょうか？」
「ああ  わかりました  どうぞどうぞ」
という場合もあります
その時は二人の意見が合ったんだから
気分がいいんです  座った人も（譲って）あげた人も
でも そんなの 起こるのは 稀の稀でしょ？
だから そういう study（検討）しないで
この世の中で「他（人）に尽くしましょう」と言って
恐ろしいことやってますよ
最近は ないんだけどね  昔は私にとっても
もう うるさくて しょうがなかったんですよ
自分（長老）を救いたくて
人が来るわ 来るわ 来るわ 来るわ
ある宗教団体から 朝も来て 昼も来て
夜も来るんです
で 私もアホだから 来る人々と
結構 仲良く喋るんです
だから 私を救うことは可能だと思っているんです
私は いくら頑張っても救われませんよ
意味がないんです
そこで ある日
夜 四人 五人ぐらい来てね
12時も過ぎて まだ喋ってるんです
「なんで あなたは この宗教 信仰しないのか」と
私「これ 間違ってるから」と言うんだけど
「そう言わないで下さい
あなた方の勉強が足らないんだ」と
私は「あなたよりは勉強してますよ」と
「宗教も 哲学も 何でもかんでも」と
「え それ 全 部間違ってる勉強だ」と
だから 自分が知ってること  自分が誰かに
騙されたんだから それこそ正しいと思って
恐怖でしょう  世界に迷惑
これ 新興（宗教）組織では よく見られることで
信仰するとはその宗教は本物だと信じることだから
信じてない人々を見ると
優しくね
「この人も救ってあげたいな」と
思っちゃうんです
優しいって言うか
うるさくて切りがないんだけどね
ある日 私は大阪に急いで行くと
ある男性がちゃんと しっかりした制服を着て
「どうですか  あなた宗教に興味
ありますか？」と言うので
「大いに興味ありますよ  あなた（私の）
服が見えるでしょうに？」
会場：[ 笑い ]
長老：「自分も何かそういう宗教のこと
ディスカッションする場所あるんだから
一緒に行きましょう」と
「どこですか？」と言うと そこから
結構遠いところなんですね
電車でも 二回 乗り換えて
行なくちゃいけないんです
「実は今 忙しくて 新幹線に乗ろうと
走ってるところだ」と言ったら
「大丈夫 大丈夫！  車が ありますから
私が一緒に行って 集まりが終わったら
また一緒に 戻してあげますよ」と
[ 笑い ]
あの教会のアホの話を聞いてね
私は私のスケジュールもチャラにしてね
何 考えてるんですかね
とにかくそういう経験たくさんありますけど
まぁ そういう方々は優しいんですよ
「あぁ この人 地獄に落ちるんだから
助けてあげなくちゃ」と思っているんです
でも それって優しいんですかね？
自分が思った世界  自分が捏造した世界が
正しいと思っているだけでしょうに
ですから 私たちには人のお世話っていうのは
他人が頼んだら
「ちょっと手を貸して」って言ったら
手を貸してあげて下さい
電車に乗れなくて「ちょっと乗るのを
助けて協力して下さい」と言われたら
サッサッサと協力してあげて
乗せてあげて下さい
それは本当に自分も気持ちいいし
相手も気持ちいいんです
だから 人がすごく喉が渇いて
「すごく喉が渇いてるんだけど何か飲物ある？」
と言ったら「あっ  あります  あります」
なかったら走って自動販売機で買って来て
「これでよろしいですか？」と
その場合は人を助けたことになりますよ
人がどこかで座って こうやって待っている
それで飲み物を買ってきて
「あのね これ 飲んで下さい」と言うと
「え⁉  なんだ これは」と
なんか 変になっちゃいますよ
「え⁉  なんだ これ？
こいつ ちょっと おかしくないの？」と
それは助けたことにならない
なぜならば 一人ひとりが自分の世界に
住んでるからなんです
ですから よく世の中で言う
「人のために生きてみて下さい」とかね
やめた方がいいんです
相当 世界に迷惑です
これは絶対的善では ないんです
だから善か悪かって ちょっと言いづらいんだけど
人に本当に必要なことをしてあげる場合は善です
問題ないんです
災害が起きたら一生懸命 行ってボランティアする
それは善行為です   問題ないんです
避難所にいる人々には何か色々持って行って
お風呂に… 仮のところ作って「じゃあ
みんな順番で お風呂に入って下さい」とかね
そういうのは抜群に善ですよ
なぜならば向こうにとっては それは必要なこと
そうでない限りはね
だから 逆に考えましょうか
「人を助けるためには 自然災害にでも
あってもらわなかったら困る」 と
変でしょう？
災害は ない方がいいでしょうに！
だから そこら辺 ちょっと
色んな矛盾があるんです
そういうわけで  自己の幸福  自分の安穏
自分の安らぎを棚にあげて
人のために頑張っちゃうと
これ エゴイストです
はい 次のスライドに行きます
はい ここから「自己中のススメ」になります
だから
自分に問題があるんです
[自分とは何？]
[認識が流れているから
「生きている」と言います]
我々は生きていますね
生きているっていうことは
我々の認識が流れているからなんです
心臓が鼓動してるからじゃないんです
だって心臓がない生命も居るでしょ？
生きてます
認識が流れてるからなんです
それで 我々にとっては 自分の体に
触れることしか知らないんだから
それが正しいと仕方がなく思うんだからね
我々には無智 あるいは無明という
「何も知らん」という状態があるんです
これ 仏教の専門用語なんです
それから 渇愛という衝動があるんです
これは みんなにあるんです
渇愛っていうのは「生きていきたい」
「死にたくない」という 気持ちなんです
この気持ちがないと 命が続かないんです
だから どんな生命も 死にたくはないんです
生きていきたいんです
それだけで 生きているんだから
要はね 地球は丸いか 四角いか 平らか
どうでもいいんです   生命にとっては
自分が生きていきたい
それから この認識に 貪・瞋・痴という
煩悩（感情）が入るんです
この貪・瞋・痴  みんな知っていますね？
欲・怒り・無智というね
無明と無智とは
微妙に tone（色合い）が違うんです
まぁ 感情と言えば たくさんありますね
仏教では たくさんあると言ったら
面倒臭いんだから 1,500あるんだと
仏教は結構 何でも数えるんです
「たくさんあります」「 少ない」とか
そういう曖昧な言葉は使わないんです
特にお釈迦様はね  ほとんど
データを数えて数字で言うんです
それは なんでかと言うと
「それで あなた方 分かる？
私は正等覚者だからなんです
知り尽くしているからだ」と
異論があったら…
例えば 「貪・瞋・痴っていうのは
ベーシック感情である三つだよ」と
「あなた できるならば
これ 四つにしてみて下さい」と
できないんです
そういうことで 絶対的にこれは事実
科学的な事実ということにするために
大体 数字で結構あります
数字の教えはね
はい  煩悩は1,500あります
[従って  認識と判断は汚れています]
私の認識は汚れています
しょうがないんです
このホールを見ると 貪・瞋・痴で見るでしょ？
その時の気分で見るでしょ？
じゃあ試験です
皆様方 ホールに入った時の気分と
今も見てください  ホールを
違うホールでしょ？
入った時のあの気分ないでしょ？
今は「あぁ いやだ  早く出て行きたい」とかね
「こいつは何時まで喋るつもりですか」という
もう相当 腹が立ってると思います
会場：[ 笑い ]
だから「このホールは いかがでしょうか？」と
聞いたとしても
「何時何分のことですか？」と
言わなくちゃいかんのです
これ 1秒単位で気持ち変わるでしょ？
だから「このホールの雰囲気はどうですか」
と言うと 馬鹿以外 答えませんよ
馬鹿は「あ～！ 気持ちいいホールで
まぁ ちょっと古いホールです」とかね
何か言うかもしれませんけどね
本当は このホールに対する自分の認識が
瞬間 瞬間 変化しているんです
だから おにぎりを取って「このおにぎりは
美味しい」ということは成り立たないんですね
その時々なんです
皆様に結構 経験があるでしょ？
「あなたのこと 大好きだ」と言う場合もあるし
「お前 見たくもない」という場合も
あるでしょうに
そういう私ですね
だから 頼りにならないね  自分というものは
だから 私たちは いつでも固定概念を作って
そちらに足が引っ張られて
足かせ 首かせ… あれやこれやとか
もう 縛られて縛られて生きているんです
「あの人は私のこと 無視したんだから
態度 悪い人だと決めちゃう」と
それでアイデアが 固定しちゃうん
です
人って秒単位で変化するんだっていうことは
無視するんです
もし 私がギャーッと喋ったら
「あ あの人は結構うるさいんだ」と
それで私は「生涯うるさい人間」と
判決を出すんでしょ？
我々は そうやって
想像できない 間違っている世界で
生きているんです　自分の世界
そういうわけで…
[従って  認識と判断は汚れています
ありのままの事実ではありません]
[判断も同じく汚れているので
判断に基づいた行為も曖昧です]
だから 認識 汚れているならば 判断するでしょ？
判断も汚れている
経済世界と同じですよ
stock market（株式市場）とかと同じですよ
みんな判断して 大失敗したり
また成功したりしますよ
成功したんだから私の判断はしっかり
当てになります　当てになりませんよ
次の判断で失敗する可能性 あります
だから 政府は色んな企画を立てる
まあ ある程度で うまくいったり
うまくいかなかったりもする
世の中 いつでもそういうことなんですね
だから 我々は判断するんでしょ
あれ とても 危険なんですね
判断も当てにならない
[ほとんど不善行為になります]
判断っていうのは大体 不善行為になります
なぜならば 貪・瞋・痴の判断だから
それで不善行為を行うと
我々は 判断して旅行するわ
判断して仕事をするわ 判断して買い物をするわ
判断して料理を作るわ とかね
色んなこと やってます  判断、判断、判断で
判断は 貪・瞋・痴でやっているんだから
大体 不善行為になります
この不善行為が溜まってくると
人生 苦しくなるんです
苦しくなってくると
さらに判断がおかしくなるんです
そういう順番ですね  生き方は
はい  次に行きます
はい それで お釈迦様が考えたのは
「一人ひとりが 自分の問題を
解決した方がいいんだ」と
「自分が幸せな人間になった方がいいのだ」と
「自分の病を 自分で治した方がいいのだ」と
「人に治療する前に 自分の病を治して下さい」と
自分の病を治したら  治療法を知っています
だから 自分が病気でどうしようもない
何すれば治るか わからない
それで 同じく病気でも 人に治療する
っていうのは 危険でしょうに！
だから やっぱり自己中の方がいいんです
正しいんです
その理由は
[Attānañce piyaṃ jañña, rakkheyya naṃ surakkhitaṃ;]
自己愛があるならば  それをしっかり護りなさい
[Tiṇṇaṃ aññataraṃ yāmaṃ, paṭijaggeyya paṇḍito.]
人生の三期（青年、中年、老年）のうち一期でも
理性の人は自己を正すのです
[Dhammapada 157]
法句経 第157偈
みんなに自己愛があるんですね
自分のこと好きなんです
本当は自分のことだけです
好きなのは
人のこと 好きじゃないんです
好きと思ってるでしょ？
好きじゃないんです
怖いね 人間は
生命も そうなんです
自分のことは好きです
他人のことは？ まぁ好きじゃないんです
ですから 我々は いとも簡単に
他の生命を敵に回します
味方に回すっていうことは至難の業なんです
経験あるでしょ？  心が通じ合う友達
作ることが至難の業でしょう？
人を無視すること  居なかったことにすること
あなた そちら勝手  私はこちら勝手に
居ることは 至って簡単です
そういうわけで 私たち一人ひとりが
自分のこと 大好きです　それは事実です
「だったら自分を護りなさいよ」と
「人を護らなくてもいいんです
自分を護りなさいよ」と
ああ ついでに言いますけど
我々には好きな人もいるでしょ？
あれは自分の都合なんです
自分を応援しているならば
自分をサポートしているならば
自分の味方になってくれるならば
その人のこと 好きです  それだけです
はい  ここで お釈迦様は優しく言うんです
「人間には三期がありますよ」と
まぁ 青年 、中年 、老年とかね
大まかに
「この一期だけでもいいんだから
心の汚れを落とせ」と
自分のこと好きでしょ？
自分のこと 好きだったら
嘘をついたり  怒ったり  嫉妬したり
喧嘩に行ったり 「何だ⁉  これは」と
喧嘩して幸せになった人がいる？
喧嘩して億万長者になった人がいる？
喧嘩して長寿になった人がいる？
喧嘩的な精神で生きてると 自分が早く老化します
病弱になります
喧嘩精神の人が病気にかかっても
薬がスローモーションで効くんです
知ったことじゃないんです
だから やっぱり 自分のために
自分の幸せのために  自分の安穏のために
「心 清らかにしなさいよ」と
「七面倒臭いと思うならば
青年 、中年 、老年  どれか選んで下さい」と
それで皆様が喜んで「分かった  私は
青年期を選びますよ」と言ったって
私は騙されませんからね [ 笑い ]
だから ブッダの話を聞いた時の年齢 考えて下さい
青年がこの話 聞いちゃうと
青年の時 実行してみます
中年が話 聞いたら 中年の時やってみるんです
老年の方々が仏教の話 聞いたら
「今 老年期に入ってるんだから じゃあ やります」
「心 清らか にします」と
決めた方がいいと思います
それから 世の中 人に教えるのは
みんな好きでたまらないね
皆さん これ 私のことだ思うかもしれません
私 喋るばっかりだからね
本当は 私の人生で一番 やりたくない
ことなんです　今やってるのは
喋りたくないんです
電話がかかってくると ものすごく
電話を壊したくなっちゃうんです
電話壊したら誰も買ってくれませんから
壊しません
あっても電話しません
だから 結構 人は他人に喋りたい
他人に お説教したい
何か 他人の先輩役をやりたい
他人の人生の案内をやりたいでしょ？
すごく うるさいんですよ
ある日 大阪で 左に行った方がいいか
右に行った方がいいか よく分からなくなっちゃって
「どうせ 駅の仕事する人が分かるでしょう」
と思ったんですね
「こちらですか？ こちらですか？」
と私は「これこれの有名な場所ですけど
行きたいんだけど どちらの方に行けば
いいんでしょうか？」と言ったら
この人は いきなり私の顔を見て
誰にも分からない英語で喋るんですね
会場：[ 笑い ]
長老："You are… you and go and…"
はあ～っ！  私は日本語で聞いたんだから
会場：[ 笑い ]
長老：やりすぎね  あの方は！
「 外人には英語しか分からない」とか
勝手に決めるんです
だから 自分の判断を人にぶつけるでしょ？
これで助け求めたんだけど
助けてもらうことは できなかったんです
だから あまりにも頑張って喋るんだから
「はい よくわかりました
ありがとうございます」と言って
サッサッと行っちゃったんです
あんまり この… [ 笑い ]
いや まだ前のスライドに居ます
p.13 に居ます
そういうことで この第158偈で
お釈迦様 その我々の問題を直そうするんですね
人にあれやこれやと…
私は専門家の訳した本を持っていなかったんだから
自分勝手に訳したんです  意訳で
だから 「人に何か言うより先に
自分でやってみて下さい」と
「人に『嘘をつくなかれ』と言う前に
自分が嘘をつかない人間になってみて下さい」と
「人に『しょっちゅう怒るなよ』と言う前に
自分が怒らない人間になった方がいい」と
やっぱり自分を直した方がいいんですね
だから 普通の人間っていうのは
「なんで あなた いつも怒りっぱなし！
怒らないで下さい！」って言うでしょ？
何だ あれは？ [ 笑い ]
この人も怒ってるんだけどね
私なら「あなた 怒ってるでしょう？」
それだけ
私はそれを冗談で取って
何か自分の楽しみにする
「あなた 怒ってるでしょう？」
で 向こうは「馬鹿にするんじゃない」
ということで怒りを消すんです
まぁ とにかく「自分が先にやって下さい」
「自分の心  先に清らかにして下さい」
「お節介は それからですよ」と
これで必ず「人のお世話を後回しにして下さい」と
「まず自分が幸せになって下さい」という話です
はい 次の ページに行きます
これ仏教はすごい強烈に言ってる
フレーズなんです
これ他の宗教も頭の中に あるんだけどね
第160偈
Attā hi attano nātho
「あなたを救ってくれるのはあなただけだよ」と
ko hi nātho paro siyā
「他人はあなたに何もやってくれないんだよ」と
他人に頼んでも「お願いします  お願いします」
とかね　成り立たないんです
我々いつでも「お願いします」とか
まぁ お祈り人生ですね
まぁ 宗教があってもなくても
お祈りというのは誰かに頼むっていうことなんですね
その人も困ってるならばどうしましょうかね
とにかく それは心理的に科学的に
成り立たないんです
一人ひとりが生きることは大変なんです
神々も一人ひとり生きることは大変なんです
これで「助けてちょうだい」と言うと
「それどころじゃないよ！」と
ですから 自分の幸せ  自分で作らなくちゃいけない
自分の救いを 自分でやらなくちゃいけない
ですから「自分を正しく
しっかり制御するならば  戒めるならば
究極の安穏に達しますよ」と
あの認識問題  捏造問題  解決すれば
究極の安穏です
それから 皆様 神話物語で聞いたことあるでしょ？
「人間は原罪ですよ」と
「人間なら罪人だ」とかね
仏教は そういうものを認めません
色んな国々で
色んな神々を信仰してる国がありますからね
ハワイでもね 何か神が居て 女神が居て
怒って火山をあれやこれや やってるんだとかね
で 日本でも あるかもしれませんね
女神が怒って人を破壊させたとかね
それって言うのは  自然の流れは
別にどうってことはないんだけど
お釈迦様が言うのは
「自分が悪いことをするならば
自分が汚れるんだ」と
[悪行為は自分が犯すのです]
[悪は自分から発生します]
[ダイヤをダイヤで削るように
自己から発生した悪は自分を破壊する]
すっごく いいフレーズですよ
他人が自分を破壊しません
自分が心 汚れちゃうと 自分の心が
それで自分が壊れて 壊れて行くんです
怖いんですよ  だから 怒り 持ってるでしょ？
欲 持ってるでしょ？ 嫉妬持ってるでしょ？
落ち込み 持ってるでしょ？
憎しみ 持ってるでしょ？
恨み 持ってるでしょ？
失望感 持ってるでしょ？
逆に すごい希望 持ってるでしょ？
そういうもので自分 削られるんです
で 破壊 破壊 破壊に 行くんです
はい 次のチャプターに行きます
そういうわけで 全て自己責任
Attanā hi kataṃ pāpaṃ, attanā saṃkilissati;
[自分が犯す悪行為によって自分が汚れる]
Attanā akataṃ pāpaṃ, attanāva visujjhati;
[悪行為を犯さない人は清らかになる]
そういうわけで「清らかな浄の人間になるか
不浄の人間になるか あなた次第です」と
いかに個人に  お釈迦様は
すごい立ち場をあげているんです
「私はあなたを清らかな人間にしてあげますよ」
ってのは ないんです
そうじゃなくお釈迦様の態度が上ですね
「いえ  自分でやって下さい」と
「自分が汚れた生命になるか
清浄な生命になるかっていうことは
自分次第
スイッチは自分が持っていますよ」と
そういうわけで 「自己責任」ですよ
[人は人を清らかにしないんです]
はい 次に行きます
これって面白いポイント  これは
何か人間ってのは堕落する運命で生まれてるんです
[こころは無明と感情の土台の上で機能しますから
人は堕落するのは自然の流れです]
落ち込まないでください
我々は堕落するようなシステムで できてるんです
みんな そのまま生きていれば
そのまま堕落して堕落して地獄まで行きます
プログラムは できてます
理由は 物を見ると 物を聞くと
物を嗅ぐと 味わうと
体に何か触れると 何か考えると
貪・瞋・痴で やっているんです
無明でやっているんです
感情でやっているんです
例えば 映画館で映画見るって言うと 感情でしょ？
何でも
それで人は堕落していくんですね
ですから それは至って分かりやすいんです
Sukarāni asādhūni, attano ahitāni ca;
この意味は
[自分に不幸を招く悪行為なら  犯すのは容易いです]
でしょ？　経験がある？
悪いことなら やりやすいでしょ？
誰でも同じです
至って簡単に悪いことする
[自分のためになる 良い結果をもたらす
行為を行うことはとても難しいのです]
Yaṃ ve hitañca sādhuñca,
taṃ ve paramadukkaraṃ.
paramadukkaraṃ っていうのは
「とっても とても難しい」という
ちょっと考えます
子供が居る　子供に言って
「遊ぼう」「勉強しよう」
どちらを選ぶ？
じゃあ どちらを選ぶか わからないけど
どちらが楽？
遊ぶこと  楽でしょ？
子どもは「じゃ 勉強します」と選ぶかも
でも それは楽じゃないんです
「朝寝坊する」「 早起きする」
どちらが楽？
分かりますね？
「怠ける」 「頑張る」
どちらが楽？
そういうことで 自分を破壊する感情 生き方なら
やりやすくて やりやすくて
「何だ⁈ この仕組みは」と
怒りたくなりますね
それは 誰かが やったわけじゃなくて
我々の捏造世界  認識の問題です
すごい簡単に終了できます
はい 次に行きます
まぁ そろそろ終わると思います
そこで この「他人のため」っていうことは
一貫して否定できないフレーズなんですよ
だって俗世間が「他人のためにやること 素晴らしい
これこそ聖人の道だ」とか言ってるんだから
何も分かってないのに
お釈迦様が言うのは… これ ちょっと
日本語訳が中々できなくて 英訳を出しましたけど
Attadatthaṃ paratthena, bahunāpi na hāpaye;
Attadatthamabhiññāya, sadatthapasuto siyā.
Do not lose your own welfare
for the sake of other's welfare.
まぁ 英語で言えばね
Clearly understand your own welfare
which is the attainment of enlightenment.
Therefore, work hard to be a liberated one.
で まぁ 英語はどうでもいいんです
日本語に入ります
[自分のために尽くすことに専念して]
あ！間違った  [他人のために
尽くすことに専念して
自分の幸福を破壊してはならない]
「『人のため』『人のため』と言って
自己破壊しないでください」と
人にできることは  誰にだってできることは
自分の幸福を作ることです
例えば 人に…
スマートウォッチ： [ 呼び出し音 ] [ メッセージ ]
長老：はぁぁ… [ ため息 ]
会場： [ 笑い ]
長老： [ 笑い ] うるさい と言うと…
例えば 我々はね あの…
スマートウォッチ： [ 呼び出し音 ]  [ メッセージ ]
会場： [ 笑い ]
みんな色々なプログラム使うんだから
これ オフすることはできません
電源 完全に消すしかないんです
で 人に ご飯 作ってあげることは できますけど
美味しく感じるか 幸せ感じるかっていうことは
その人の責任なんですね
だから 私はご飯作って「あなた これ食べて
幸せを感じてください  お願いします」
成り立たないね
「はい あなた これ食べて超美味しく感じて下さい
お願いします」
成り立ちますかね？
だから この余計なことを…  人がお腹が
空いているならば何か作ってあげて下さい
スマートウォッチ： [ 呼び出し音 ]  [ メッセージ ]
会場： [ 笑い ]
これスワチャにあげたら
もうスワチャが知ってる人ですけど
そういうわけで まぁ人が人を助けても
いいんだけど
それは物理的にできますよ
ご飯 作ってあげることはできます
が 「美味しく感じてよ」「幸せ感じてよ」とか
これ やめて下さい
それは その人の責任です
だから自分が幸せを感じることをすればいいんです
こちらではっきり言うのは「他人のために
と言うことで気をつけて下さい」と
「一番大事なのは自分の安穏だよ」と
「自分の幸福だよ」と
だから 人の幸福とは皆様 分からない
人の幸福というのは我々の心にある認識トラブル
何でも誤解する あの問題
「我が輩は唯一正しいのだ」と思ってる
あの愚かさを直すことです
そんなに難しいことでもないんです
で それは仏教で「解脱に達する」と言うんですね
「それに頑張ってくださいよ」と
はい 次
Go to next page.  18
そういうわけで また色々 教典 出しますけど
まぁ あんまり なくてもいいんで
もう今日の ポイントは 終わったと思いますよ
ブッダの時代でコーサラっていう国があって
コーサラ国王という
言うことを聞く  言うこと聞かない
どちらかも分からない王様が居たんです
結構 凶暴な王様でね
お釈迦様とは仲良しでね
お釈迦様は コーサラ国に住んでいたんですね
このコーサラ国王が言うのは
「人が 身・口・意（しんくい）で」
まぁ「 身（しん）」っていうのは体で
「口（く）」というのは言葉で
「意（い）」っていうのは 考えることで
「悪行為するならば
その人は自分を守っていないんだ」と
「自分の敵だ」と
これ王様の経験でもありますよ
このコーサラ王様は結構 乱暴な人ですけど
ブッダと 親しいのだから
いい人間になりたいという気持ちもあるんです
だから政治家は 信頼できませんからね
いい人間にもなりたいとか
それで 犯罪（を犯）した人々を王様のところに
最終判決のために（連れて）来るんです
王様のところに 犯罪者が捕まえられて来る場合は
とっくに裁判 終わってるんです
罪を犯したことは確かです
でも裁判官は判決はしません
それは王様の権利
王様が 「その人 打首」っていう風に
言わなくちゃいけないんです
「こいつ 手を切る」とかね
「この人は両足と手を切る」とかね
「この人 追放」とか色々
「この人牢獄」
王様 決めるんです
でも王様 朝から そればっかりやってると
気持ち悪いでしょ？
かわいそう 王になっちゃって
で それで この人が「王様すみません
私が愚か者で
性格が悪くて罪を犯しました
私の間違いです
どうか王様が自分次第で判断して下さい」と頼むと
王様が「分かった」と言って
ちょっと許してあげたい気持ちがあるんです
打首をやめて まぁ一年 牢とかね
何とかしたいんですね
しかし この人々が「何で？王様
私は何の悪いこともしていない
私を恨んでる人々は私を嵌めましたよ」とか
言うと 王様が「こいつは嘘を言う」
「嘘のことを考えている」
そうすると牢に入れたいと思った人 に
「じゃあ 打首」と
なっちゃうんですね
だから 皆様も輪廻転生する時は
王にならないように気をつけて下さい
全然 楽じゃない
楽しくないんです 王家で生まれることは
はい だけど ここでもっと具体的に言うのは
人々というのは 一番 偉い連中は軍隊に守られてるでしょ？
アメリカの大統領みたいに
アメリカの大統領はね  まぁ大阪かどこかに
行くならば ここまで軍隊 警察 動いてるんです
ここでもアメリカの軍人の飛行機が…
「そこまで… 何だ⁉」と
「そこまで守っていても  その人が
身・口・意で悪行為をしているならば
意味がありません」と
「自分が考えるときは 悪いことを考える
喋るときは 悪いことを喋る
何かやったら悪いことをするならば
自己破壊になるのだよ」と
これ 王様の哲学
お釈迦様も「そうだよ」と
「本当のガードっていうのは
軍隊にガードされてることじゃないんだ」と
「内からガードして下さい
身・口・意を守って下さい」と
これで みんなに お釈迦様が仰ったのは
「自分を守りなさい」
どうやって守るのかと（言うと）
身・口・意で悪行為しないことにする
ものすごい立派な 良い方になる
はい これはコーサラさんが言ったね
はい 次に行きます
ちょっと触れてみたんだけど福祉活動
福祉活動 色々あるんです
一番目　[助け合いの関係]
助け合い   互いに助け合わないと
社会人として生きられないんですね
だから 我々は公園だったら汚さないし
色々 互いに助け合って
交通ルールを守ったりもするし
ねぇ？  守りますかねぇ？ [ 笑い ]
守らなかったら大変ですけど
一応 お互いに助けてるんですよ
だから スーパーでちゃんと買い物して並んでいる
それも立派な行為でしょ？
並ばないで前から出しちゃうと
いかに悪行為かと分かるでしょう？
だからスーパーで買い物かごを持って
ちゃんと並んでいる　平和ですね
問題なく自分の番が来たら ちゃんとレジで
お金 精算して品物持って帰る
そういうものも あまり軽く見ないで下さいよ
バスに乗りたければ ちゃんとバス停で
じっと待っている
そちらも 人々四人ぐらい居るならば
その順番でバスに乗る
これ決まってる　ルール守ること
それで我々は互いに助け合っているんです
これは気持ちいいんです
それで ある年の方はバスに乗ると ちょこちょこと
乗れなくなったりしたりすると
運転手さんか 後ろに居る人は
ちょっと助けてあげて
あるいは 今はカードですけど
お金入れなくちゃいけないんだけど
このお年の方は お金入れると ちょこっと落ちると
すると誰かが それを拾ってあげて
運転さんも「あ 大丈夫 大丈夫」
そうやって助け合うんでしょ？
美しいでしょ？
だから 平和な世界っていうのは
ひとつの福祉活動みたいなもんですよ
大事に考えてるといいんです
人は社会に対して自分の義務を果たすんですね
それだけじゃなくて  私たちも
やらなくちゃいけない義務がいっぱいありますね
税金 払うこととか  それは払わなても
取られてますから大丈夫ですけど [ 笑い ]
色々 義務があるんですね
それは大体みんなやってます 福祉活動は
二番目なんですね
二番目
[相手から何も求めない福祉活動]
我々は税金払ってるんだけど
国からも色んなものを求めてますよ
「公園をきれいにしなさい」とかね
「街灯 しっかり付けて下さい」とかね
それでお互い助け合っている
相手から何も求めない福祉活動もありますね
[自分と比較して恵まれない人々]
自分の状況を見ると この人はちょっと
経済的に 物理的に 苦しんでるように見える
その人を助ける
あるいは 不幸に遭遇している人々を
自分の力の範囲で助けてあげる
だって いくら平和で豊かで幸せで生きて
いたとしても 地震が起きたら全部終わりですからね
そういう時は 地震が起きてない場所の人々が
助けてあげなくちゃいけない
その場合は何も 向こうからは
求めていないんですね
それは なんで素晴らしいかと言うと
その時も エゴイストの気持ちを
抑えなくちゃいけないんです
だから福祉活動自体で人は助かりせんよ
その人 その時だけ
時間かかる
復興するまでは
復興しても 誰かが亡くなっちゃうと
やっぱり落ち込みますよ
家が潰れた
そこで新しい家を作った
政府の援助もあって作った
だから 万々歳  幸せ でもない
誰かが亡くなったんですね
これ 苦しみがあるんですね
だから まぁ そんなもんですよ
で まぁ とにかく それでも我々は
何かちょっと不幸にあった人  ちょっと
色んな理由でね 「あ  この人困っている」と
これは物理的に見えるんですね
だから助けられます
精神的に悩んでる場合は
専門家が何とかしなくちゃいけない
それが自分のエゴを戒めるから
善行為になります
はい  これでラストでしたっけ？
司会：もうちょっとです
長老：うん
[信仰世界で]…  まぁ ここら辺は 跳ばして
終わりにしても いい みたいな [ 笑い ]
まぁ 余計な話だと思いますけど
みんな 疲れているしね
この「利他行」という 日本ではよく
特に仏教世界で 日本のね
よく言われることで
仏教っていうのは平和な宗教でしょ？
だから初めから互いに喧嘩して別れてるんです
会場：[ 笑い ]
平和な宗教だからしょうがないでしょ
戦争しないと
まぁ 戦争っていうのは
体でもって戦争はしていないんだけど
初期仏教  私が教えるお釈迦様オリジナルと
大乗仏教という 二つ大きなのがあって
それから密教仏教とか チベット仏教とか
色々別れて別れてやっています
そこで お釈迦様のオリジナル仏教に
「小乗仏教」と すっごい差別用語 使ってますね
やっぱり 仏教徒だから そういうふうに
人を差別しなくちゃ いかんのです
会場：[ 笑い ]
長老：だから いかに悪行為するのかっていう目的で
仏教の連中 生きてるんだからね
もう しょうがないんです
そこで 特に大乗仏教で
私たち初期仏教の人々のことを
「あなた方は 自分の解脱ばっかし
目指しているでしょうに」と
「だから あまりにも我が儘だ」と
「人の救いのために頑張りなさい」
「頑張らないねぇ  だから我々は偉い
私たちは人の救いのために頑張っている」
「従って大乗
乗り物は かなり大きい」
大きすぎて乗り物は動かないんです
会場：[ 笑い ]
長老：だって買い物に行きたければ
自転車ぐらいで いいでしょうに
新幹線に乗る馬鹿が居るんですかねぇ？
だから 大きくないんだけどね
もう人間っていうのは喧嘩好きでしょ？
だから もう 大乗経典 小乗経典
どんな経典を読んでみたとしてもね
まぁ 大したことは ないんだけどね
そういうことで 利他行 利他行 利他行
という言葉が出てきて
私たちは 「自利」やってるんだと
「自分のことしか考えてないんだよ」と
非難するんですね
非難するわするわ  大乗仏教の方々は
我々 一度も聞いてあげてないんです
「どうぞ頑張って下さい」と
聞かない
なぜかと言うと 初めから
別な電車に乗っているんです
いくら目的…[ 笑い ]
大阪に来た人が
東北新幹線に乗っているんです
言っても聞いてくれないんだから
「どうぞ」と
そんな感じで まぁ 我々は聞いてあげませんよ
「あなた方は もう自利行でしょう！」とかね
「それで？」で それで終わり
私は聞いた
「あなた方は利他行ですかねぇ？」とかね
特に大乗仏教は我々と同じ仲間だから
大乗仏教のこと言ったんだけど
やっぱり宗教世界で この利他行を
あまりにも謳っているんですね
あれ よく見ると すっごい迷惑なんで
人類には
もう犯罪 起こすんですよ
あのアフリカとかね
特にヨーロッパの missionary（宣教師）の方々は
やったことっていうのは
犯罪そこそこっていう…
で まあ いいんだけど
だから 人のためにってやっちゃうと
人権  尊厳  壊しちゃうし
だから それぞれの地方の人々は
自分なりの信仰を持っている
だから勝手にその信仰でいればいいでしょうに
なんで別な誰かの文化の信仰を
受け取らなくちゃいけないんですかね？
で そこでも すごい無理やり強引なことを
しちゃうんで  それは利他行じゃないんですね
[利他行は自分の修行です]
だから 自分の修行として
やらなくちゃいけないし
だから 実際 利他行って何なのかと
理解しなくてはいけないんですね
だから 人は自分のエゴの気持ちをね
どんどん すり減らしてなくしたい
だから 自分のことより先に 人のことを考える
だったら利他行でもあり
正しい行為でもあります
自分が食べる前に相手はどうでしょうかと
だから エゴの気持ちをなくすならば
利他行は成り立ちます
[こころが汚れる、エゴイストになってしまう、
自慢するための実績になる利他行は
自分の成長の妨げになります]
「私はこれぐらい やりましたよ」とかね
実績作りたくて人を助けるならば
それは あまり道徳範囲にはならないんですね
問題は人格向上なんです
自分のエゴをなくすことです
エゴをなくして なくして なくして
自分が消えちゃうんです
ですから 本当に
心を清らかにすることが唯一の仕事であって
人の心を清らかにさせることは
ちょっと不可能です
そういうわけで 私個人が
自分の心 清らかにする修行すると
その修行の結果として 人も助かります
私の欲をなくすために 私が持ってる物の
愛着を減らして みんなと分けて使います
そういう風に
自利・利他は区別できないんです
人を助けたことによって 自分の自我が
いくらか なくなったならば それで○（マル）、ＯＫです
人を助けて「ほら 私は人を助けましたよ」
って言っちゃうと ×（バツ）、アウトで
これ微妙なところ 理解して欲しいんです
自分のエゴが減っていくのかと
そういうことで 単独で利他行を謳っては いけない
初期仏教では 利他・自利という
二つに分離していないんです
一種の道徳  一項目なんです
はい  次に行きます
司会：これで 最後です
長老：うん
そこで最後
利他行できる人がいます
みんなにできない
[人格向上を完成した人
心を清らかにした人
無智を破って智慧を開発した人
自我の錯覚が消えた人
要するに覚者です]
気をつけて欲しい
悟る前は 自分の心 清らかにして下さい
余計なことをしないで
[覚者の行為はすべて利他行です]
自我をきれいに… 自我は錯覚
これが消えた人の行為は
敢えて言わなくても利他行なんです
他人の幸福になるんです
たとえ覚者が黙っていても
周りの人々は その影響を受けて
心 清らかになるんです
すごい力 持っています
そういうわけで 覚者に得るべき…
なんで覚者の行為は利他行かと言うと
[覚者は得るべきものは一切ないんです]
だから 純粋に利他行です
はい  話は それで終了でございます
はい  ありがとうございます
会場：[ 拍手 ]
司会：スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございます
お時間 あと30分ほど ございますが
どういたしますか？
質疑応答 いたしましょうか？
このままの流れで よろしいですかね？
お手洗いとか行かれる方は
ご遠慮なく行かれていただいて
ちょっと時間あるので
質疑応答をしたいと思います
すいません マイク係の方 いらっしゃいますか？
ご質問ある方 挙手いただけますか？
では 前の方から順に マイクを
長老：質問があったら 私は隠れて答えます
司会：どうぞ
質問者①：よろしくお願いします
警察公安が理由なく私を襲って
一生治らない大怪我をさせるんです
しかも証拠隠滅捏造もしています
警察公安が無断で家の敷地内に入ってきて
玄関の鍵を開けて家の中に入り 中を壊しています
物を盗んでいます　情報を盗んでいます
警察公安がトイレに毒を投げ込んで
喉を痛くさせます
警察公安が評判を落とすための嘘の噂を流します
警察公安が検閲をします
欲しいものがあれば 抜き取っています
司会：すいません　質問だけ手短にお願いします
質問者①：はい　えーと
・・・運輸は知らんぷりして それを私に渡します
で  こういう…
こういう…どうしたらいいでしょうか？
長老：あのねぇ 落ち込まないで 何とか
自己を守る 色々 工夫を考えて下さい
それは もしかすると 自分自身の
公案、レッスン、宿題かもしれませんね
まぁ そういうのは本当に誰がやっているのか
っていうことはね
えーと  あれ何て言いますか？
カメラね  ビデオカメラ 付けておかないとね
分からないしね
例えば ビデオカメラ付けて そちらに記録あったらね
法律的に何とかできるし
でないと どうにもならんしね
だから まぁ 生きる時 出てくるトラブルは
何でも自分自身の修行であると
自分が そこは どうやって乗り越えるのかと
落ち込まないで どうやっていられるのかと
何があっても どうやって笑って生活できるのか
っていうことは大事じゃないかなと思いますね
だから 我々には 夏 蚊が来ることは
ストップできませんし
家にゴキブリ 入ることは どうしようもないしね
そういう風に みんな生きてるんだからね
色々 トラブルっていうものは ありますね
しかし その時でも いつだって落ち着いて 明るく
あまりにもトラブルだったら
どうやって それ避けるのかとかね
いう風に 頭を使って 方便を考えて
生きるための機会ではないかとは思いますね
はい  説明は以上でございます
司会：はい  ありがとうございます
他の方どなたか
じゃあ 真ん中の列の方
質問者②：人との会話をする時に できるだけ
自分の心を汚さないような会話の仕方と言うか
気をつけるべきことと言うか
ございましたら 何かポイントを教えて下さい
長老：はあ…　[ 笑い ]
いきなり難しい問題 出されますからね
これは 難しいよ
でも 道徳を侵さないで喋って欲しいんですね
道徳を侵すということは
自分の感情を押し付けることなんです
ただ facts（事実）だけ理解できるように
面白く喋ればいいんです　それでも人の心が
汚れるかどうか保証はできませんけどね
例えば「これは いけないでしょう!!」と言った途端
自分の怒りを出していますね
人に データではなく
怒りの感情 送信したんですね
だから客観的に「こうなっちゃうとねぇ
これ うまくいかないねぇ
やり方はそうじゃないしね
別なやり方あるでしょう」とか
データだけ 伝えることですよ
それは簡単じゃないよ
自分の修行になります  訓練すると
ただデータだけ伝える
それから 怒りは みんな嫌がりますから
ユーモアは みんな好きなんです
だから できるだけ明るく
相手が失敗したとしても
「まぁまぁ もう人間だからねぇ」とかね
「人間だから それって当たり前だ」と
「でも やるなよ」と言った方が
みんな 相手も「あ 面白い話し方だ」
と思って理解するんです
そういうことで「 1.感情伝えることは悪行為」
それは やめましょう
伝えるときは データだけ伝えなくちゃいけない
それで方便として 面白く 楽しく 語る
というところですね
できるだけ ギャアギャアと
感情を出すことだけは やめましょう
はい
司会：他の方 どなたか挙手いただいて…
では一番 奥側の列の
中段の一番 端っこの方
質問者③：ありがとうございました
初めての参加なので 色々理解が
足りてないところがあると思うんですけれども
本日のお話の中でもあった社会福祉
いわゆる利他というものが
自分の中でよく理解できてなくて
誰かのために何かするっていうことが
結果 誰かが得をして 自分が損をしてしまうように
感じてしまって 人のためにっていうのが
すごい何か損得勘定が先に出て 嫌なんですよ
でも それじゃいけないなっていうのは
理解はしてるんですけれども
なかなか気持ちが変わらなくて
こういった考え方って
自分の中の考え方を変える方法
どうやれば変わるんでしょうか？
長老：うーん 質問のポイントは
あまり出てこなかった
司会：利他的な行為をしようとする時に
どうも自分の中で損得勘定が先に来てしまう
そういう自分の心の不純さというか
そういうところを変えていくにはどうしたらいいか
長老：うん うん
だから すごいベーシックです  問題は
利他とは あなた 何か物をあげると
思ってるんですかねぇ？
その場合は損得勘定なんですけどね
じゃあ 別な例え
例えば自分が大人で 勉強する子供が居る
ちょっと何か 勉強 問題 引っかかっちゃって
分からない状態で引っかかってると
「あのね これは こういう風に
考えれば 解決できますよ」と
すごく面白く優しく教えてあげる
それで子供も「あぁ 助かりました
おじいさん ありがとうございました」
って言うでしょ？
利他行でしょうに
それで子供に「お前に教えたんだから
5,000円ちょうだい」じゃないでしょうに
だから 利他行っていうのは
互いに助かることでしょうに
人を助けると どうしても自分も助かりますよ
例えば人を助けて… この助けてって言うのは
物をあげることじゃないんです
物をあげることは ほんのわずか
もう 16分の1でもないんです
時々 これ 言っていいかどうかわからないんだけど
みんな親切に色んな物を私にくれますけど
時々 絶対 使わない物だから どうしようかと
返って…
処分できなくてね
ゴミ処理もできなくて
だから ゴミに出す…
人がせっかくあげた物 ゴミ に出す気持ちも
ちょっと失礼じゃないかなと
思ったりしたら 困るでしょうに！
それより私を見て「あぁ こんにちは
元気？」
と言った方が「元気よ！」その方が楽なんです
まぁ コーヒー飲みたいのに 紅茶出しちゃうと
何か ややこしいですね
とにかく 人を助けるっていうこと
人だけじゃないよ
生命を助けることで
これは物をあげるだけじゃないんです
大体 普通 みんな「あっ 物をあげる！」
っていうことと思っちゃうんですね
物をあげるのは その物が欠けてる人なんですよ
高いレストランでディナー食べてる人に
弁当買ってきて「これも食べて下さい」と
言うのは 意味がないでしょうに！
だから弁当を買ってきてあげるならば
それなりの…
今 あまり見当たらないんだけど
ホームレスの方々とかね
ちょっと そういう方々いるんですね
それで「じゃあ これとこれ 食べて」と あげたら
その人は それ取って食べるでしょうし
でも 自分が何か得たような気がしますよ
自分として何か価値あることをやった と
そちら 何も損していないんです
例えば 何で人間に金が必要でしょうかと言うと
これは英語の単語で言えば
"satisfaction" でしょ？
「満足」でしたっけ？
だから 心の「ああ 良かった」という
気持ちのためでしょ?!  生きてるのは
だから お金じゃないよ
例えば お金があって高級な車を買う
買っても ビニールシート貼っても
そのまま 一度もどこにも行かない
そこで どんなサティスファクションですかね？
だから 車 買ったからと言って迷惑だけで
自然破壊で
でも それに乗って 音楽も入れて
それで旅をする
その時 楽しみが生まれるんでしょうに
だから みんな この「お金、お金」で考えるところ
結構 間違ってますよ
我々は…英語の単語で覚えて下さい
"satisfaction"  探してるんです
これ 日本語にすると満足っていうふうに
満足って意味じゃなくて
「何となく良かっ たなあ」とか「ああ 楽しいなあ」
という気持ちなんです
それで 何で公園に散歩するのかと言うと
楽しいからでしょうに！
それで 「あぁ 一日一万歩  歩かなくちゃいけない
これは もう私の義務としてやる」と言うと
苦しいんです
そうではなくて「じゃあ散歩しよう
楽しくねぇ
鳥が居るなら 鳥も見ながら
花が咲いてるならば それも見ながら
虫が居たら 虫のことも観察しながら」
で 何となく人生 楽しくなるんで
だから 人助けっていうのは
その辺にあるものなんですね
相手に楽しみを与える
"satisfaction" を与える
それは 金だけでは ありません
色々あります
そういうテーマで考えて下さい
はい
司会：はい  他に質問ある方いらっしゃいますか？
長老：こちらの…
この真ん中の…
質問者④：本日 お話にあった
「不善行為は苦を作る」ってことなんですけど
不善行為をするのは簡単ということで
ただ正しい行為をする人間になることが大切だ
ということを仰ってらしたと思うんですが
その正しい行いっていうのは
自分で考えた正しい行いだと
判断が混じってるので不善になってしまうかな
と思うんですけど  具体的にどういうことが
正しい行いかを教えていただきたいです
長老：ああ それは…
我々は なんで不善行為するのかと言うと
生命の衝動
これは無明と貪・瞋・痴なんですね
それは実感…
無明はあまり実感できないんだけど
まぁ こういうふうに理解を
「分からないことは一杯あるんだよ」と
「何も分かってないくせに生きてますよ」と
そういうふうに理解すれば
これ 無明の管轄ですね
それで 貪・瞋・痴は大体 分かりますね？
その場合は 痴と無明は同じですけど
まぁ 「アホなこと」というふうに
シンプルに理解して下さい
欲と 怒りと アホな下らないことをやるとかね
その心の 自分の中にある この悪い emotion（感情）
を戒しめる行為は 何であろうとも善行為です
だから 客観的に「この行為」「この行為」
というふうに言う必要は ないんです
例えば まぁ 怠けてわがままになってくる
わがままになると 何となく体が動かないんですよ
一緒に怠けも入ってくるんですね
それで 自分の感情をチェックする
わがままで 怠けが来て 何かちょっと暗い
「これ 破ろう」と思って公園のゴミ拾いをする
心が明るくなっていくんです
あるいは公園にいる人々と ちょっと
挨拶してみる  喋ってみる
そういうふうに 善行為 いくらでも考えれば現れますよ
これは リストに自分を束縛する必要はないんです
いつでも 内から 中で チェックするんです
どんどん自分が明るくなっていくことは
体感します
そうすると「あ これは どんどん育てましょう」
っていうふうになるんです
だから何が善行為かっていうことは
その人が発見した道がある
発見できる道があるんです
これ自分で発見すると 自分の智慧が現れるんです
智慧が現れると 無明が減っていくんです
そういうプログラムです
分かった？
質問者④：ありがとうございます
長老：うん
司会：挙手していただけますか？
一番前の方に
長老：それと後ろに また二人 居るんです
司会：順番にお願いします
ちょっと手をあげていて下さい
質問者⑤：ありがとうございます
自分のエゴを抑えていくには
具体的にどういったことをしていけば
よろしいでしょうか？
司会：自分のエゴを抑えていくには
具体的に どういうことをしていけばいいか
長老：うーん…  ずっと それ喋ってたんだけどねぇ
会場：[ 笑い ]
質問者⑤：すいません  ちょっと
理解できてないところがあるんで
長老：じゃあ まぁ ずうっとそれ喋ってきたんだけど
ポイント たくさんで結構 智慧が必要ですよ
で まず このポイントだけ覚えて下さい
質問者⑤：はい
長老：「私が思う」ね 「私が考える」
両方とも当てにならない
私が思ったからと言って正しいわけじゃない
これ私の主観です
私が考えたからと言って
私は間違ったデータ合わせて考えたんだから
あてにならない
でも 今は精一杯 これしかできん
質問者⑤：はい
長老：でしょ？
自分が何か考えたら ご自分の精一杯でしょ？
それも理解して
だからと言って正しくはないんだと
いう感じで執着を減らすんです
それで誰かが  友達が 考えを聞いて
「あのね お前 本当におかしい」
と言われたとしましょう
エゴがあったら腹が立つんです
その時「えっ？ そう？ そう思うの？
ちょっと説明してくれませんか」と
で  その人の version（意見）も聞いてみる
その人の version（意見）を聞いて
自分の思考を いくらか訂正する
そういうふうに生きてみるんです
「いわゆる固定した自分は存在しない」と
「いつでも変化して発展している自分だ」と
変化するのは変化しますけど
変化は「発展」っていうことにするんです
そういう考えで生きてみれば
残念ながら仏教っていうのは科学なんですよ
新興宗教じゃないんです
だから ちょっと難しく感じる可能性あります
で 今言ったことは心理学的に正しいと
こちら思う生き方でそこをちょっとやってみて下さい
質問者⑤：はい  ありがとうございます
司会：はい その後ろの方で手をあげてらっしゃった方
いらっしゃいますよね？
じゃ ちょっと そのままマイクを
後ろに回していただけますか
質問者⑥：ありがとうございます
比較的始めの方で
自分の世界っていうものが
自分の妄想から出来上がった世界を
それぞれが持ってるっていう話を仰っていて
それが すごく腑に落ちたんですけど
自分の世界を作る時には 結構 嘘を
つくことがあると思うんですよね
仕事でうまいこと行かなかった時に
「あれは運が悪かっただけだ」とか
あるいは「あれは何かしたから
祟りとかバチが当たったんだ」みたいな感じで
自分をごまかしたり そういう嘘をつくことが
あると思うんですけど
やっぱりそういうことは
良くないことなんでしょうか？
長老：うーん…
まぁ 物事 断言的に良い・良くない
って言うことは難しいんだけど
まぁ…
時々 そういう経験もありますね
どちらにしても自分の主観だからね
「まぁ 別に」っていう感じでいればね
じゃあ 論理的なポイント言いますよ
「自分の見解に囚われるなよ」と
見解っていうのは その時 その条件で
作った精一杯のことかも
でも データ変わり次第 入り次第
観察能力 成長する次第で
見解は改良しなくちゃいかんですね
だから 我々は もう…
思ったことは そのまま正しいと思って
そこでストップしちゃうんですね
そこは ちょっとやめた方がいいんですよ
まぁ そういうことで 「いつでも
見解を停止して 停止していきましょう」と
質問者⑥：分かりました
ありがとうございます
司会：まだ若干お時間ございますけど
長老：あの後ろ二人ぐらい手を…
司会：じゃあ 順番にマイクをお渡ししていきます
質問者⑦：すいません
ありがとうございます
ひとつ質問がありまして
自分の個人的なことなんですが
一番初めに 自分自身で世界をそれぞれ作ってる
っていうことで それは認識します
人それぞれ それぞれの世界があるということで
で  ちょっと自分の個人的なことで
夫婦間の旦那さんの方も
やはり自分の世界を自分で作っている
それも理解できます
で その旦那さんが作っている怒りとか
それは怒りっていうのは自分自身で作っている捏造
捏造を怒りで旦那さん自身が作っている場合
で こちらは相手を助ける必要はない
助けてはいけない
それは お互いの世界だからっていうことなんですが
そういった場合は助けることもできない
本人が作っている捏造の世界
こういったことは私としてはどのように
もう ただ「彼の世界です」「私 の世界です」
「別々です」っていうことで続けていくべきなのか
ちょっと分からなくて質問させてもらいました
長老：はい
まぁ 夫婦ですから
いくらか相手の生活に入り込む
権利がありますからね
完全に入り込む権利はないんだけど
いくらか入り込む権利はありますね
ですから…
向こうが怒りで苦しんでる場合は
「まぁまぁ あなたの世界のことは置いといて
今は楽しく二人で映画でも見よう」とかね
あるいは何か「散歩にでも行こうかな」とかね
で 何となくテーマ変えて安らぎを与えるとかね
ということで助けてあげることができます
人が一番 嫌がるのは 指をさして
「これ やるなよ」って言うのはね
これ 嫌がるんですね
「怒るなよ」と言ったらいかんね
その人は仕方がなく怒っているんだからね
だから 子供が勉強しないで怠けてふざけていると
「ふざけるなよ！」って言ってはいかんね
だから 何か別な方法で
何か面白く喋ってね  雰囲気を 気持ちを
emotion（感情）をちょっと変えてあげたりすれば
例えば 子供がふざけて怠けている場合
ちょこっと何か「これこれを お願い
しますからやってくれ」とかね
何かつまらない何か頼んで
やってあげたら大いに喜んで
「おぉ！ すごいね  やってくれて
ありがとうございます」とか余計に 褒めると
子どもは「え？ 何か ちょっと変ですけど」とか
思って その気持ちで また頑張る気持ちになります
そういう風な色々工夫ありますよ
そこで それぞれ互いに助け合う
助け合っても一人ひとりが自分の世界に生きてますよ
私が思い出したのは
あるビンにビー玉を入れたような
感じなんですよ  家族っていうのは
ビンの中にビー玉が五個あると
でも五個でしょ  いつでも
溶けて一個にはなりませんね
だから ビー玉がお互いにぶつからないように
お互いに美しく見えるように
ちょっと整理しておく
それぐらいは できます
はい 頑張って下さい
There is another person.
もう一人…  はい
司会：もうひと方 手をあげてらっしゃる
質問者⑧：すいません
自分が何か失敗したり 悪いことをした時に
自分に返ってくるというのは
何となく分かるんですけれども
自分が失敗したり 悪いことをした時に
なかなか他の人に対して
「申し訳なかったな」という 気持ちが
出てこなくて
他の人に対して「申し訳なかったな」っていう
気持ちは どうやったら出てくるでしょうか？
長老：あ これはもう
あなたは すごく自我が強くて
「我が輩は 正しいんだ」という恐ろしい錯覚が
まだまだ 強いんです
だから 今日の説法で「我が輩は正しくある
はずがない」っていうことに入れ替えて下さい
だから 失敗しますよ 人間がね
失敗で人に迷惑かけたりもする
その場合は当然「申し訳ない」
っていう気持ちが必要なんです
で 「何か文句あるの？」という態度 取っちゃうと
「だから何？」という態度 取っちゃうと
これ あまりにも自我がありすぎなんですね
そこら辺でね  自分というものは決して…
自分の主観で生きてるんだから
主観っていうのは 瞬間 瞬間 変わるものだからね
あの鏡の例え  鏡って言ったら
私は 何か変な鏡を教えたでしょ
何か粘土みたいな
何か もう 動く 変化する鏡
この もう 立体的で
これは色んな形になる
だから その場その場で映る画像が変わるんですね
だから そういう鏡だったら永久的に
正しく画像が映ることは不可能ですね
だから 禅の世界ではね「鏡 壊せ」と言って
最終的な悟りを表現していますけどね
まぁ そこまで じわじわと
人は成長しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから これ ちょっと観察しないと難しいんで
いつだって私たちは「自分が正しい」
という前提で 生きているんですよ
で 帰る時はどんな風に帰ればいいかっていうことは
自分が帰る道順 考えてるでしょ？
で それは正しいと思っているんです
その場合はあまり問題は起きません
しかし 自分が決めたこと以外にも
家に帰る方法はありえる
で そんな程度はいいんでね
買い物に行く前に「これこれ 買います」
と決めて行って それを買う
店で やっぱり見たら「これより もっと
いい物あるんじゃないかな」と
思ったらどうするのか と
二つ できます
前もって決めたことを消して
もっと見つけたいいものを買うか
あるいは これを買うために来たんだから
これを買って帰るか
どちらでもいいんですね
だから いつでも自分を…
自分が正しいと（思って）
我々は誰だって生きているんだけど
その中で あまり問題ないこともあるし
停止した方が いいものもあるし
やめた方がいいものも あるしね
例えば 楽しいから麻薬を使うとかね
やめた方がいいんです
麻薬を使ってる人々は 結構楽しんでやってます
「あぁ 楽しいでしょう  じゃ どうぞ
やって下さい」は ちょっとね
そういう感じで 断言やめることもあるし
訂正するべきものもあるし
まぁ ほっといたっていいものも
色々ありますからね
それは 色々 ちょっと自分の宿題として
頑張ってみて下さい
司会：すいません
ちょっと時間が かなり押してしまったので
質疑応答 これで終了させて
いただきたいと思います
最後に「祈願文」というパーリ語の偈を
皆さんでお唱えして終了したいと思います
よろしくお願いします
長老：はい 一緒に唱えましょう
Dukkhappattā ca niddukkhā
Bhayappattā ca nibbhayā
Sokapattā ca nissokā
Hontu sabbepi pāṅino
苦しんで悩む生命が 苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が 恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が 悲しみなく
一切の生命が 安穏でありますように
Sādhu!     Sādhu!    Sādhu!
善きかな！  善きかな！  善きかな！
はい  ありがとうございます
[拍手]
事務局：本日は皆様 ご参加
ありがとうございました
お知らせが 四つ あります
まず お配りしたアンケート用紙ですが
受付を出たところで回収しています
QRコードでも回答できますので
ご協力お願いいたします
二つ目のご連絡です